bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
consacré aux tensions entre la Chine et
Taïwan alors que hier soir mardi des
troupes et des chars taïwanais ont
effectué des manœuvres de tirs réel sur
l'île du pintong au sud une île qui se
trouve entre la Chine continentale et
Taïwan lundi c'est un drone militaire
chinois qui est entré au sud-ouest de la
zone d'identification de défense
aérienne de Taïwan accompagnée de 8
avions militaires plus de 446 avions
chinois seraient entrés dans la zone
d'identification de défense aériennes de
Taïwan au mois d'août des manoeuvres
militaires sans précédent donc organisés
par Pékin pour protester notamment
contre la visite à Taipei de la
présidente de la Chambre des
Représentants américaines Nancy Pelosi
alors dans ce contexte de tension des
parlementaires français sont arrivés à
Taïwan une délégation européenne
probablement la plus importante à se
rendre sur l'île depuis la visite de
Nancy Pelosi alors étant entrer dans une
escalade des tensions que représente
Taïwan dans cette région Indo-Pacifique
jusqu'où ira quelle est la réponse
américaine quelle est la position des
Européens dans ce bras de fer entre
Pékin et Taipei Taïwan jusqu'où ira sea
Jinping on en parle avec mes invités
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
Antoine brondaz bonsoir chargé de
recherche à la frs et vous dirigez le
programme Taïwan sur la sécurité et la
diplomatie vous êtes également
enseignant à Sciences Po bienvenue dans
le débat Tamara lui bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste journaliste indépendante et
vous êtes hongkongaise qui est important
sur ce plateau merci d'être avec nous
bienvenue dans le débat à côté de vous
André valligny bonsoir vous êtes
sénateur socialiste membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense également membre du groupe
d'études Sénat Taïwan bienvenue dans le
débat bienvenue à vous Jean-François
d'imegli au bonsoir économiste et
président de l'agia ascenter merci
également d'être avec nous des troupes
et des chars taïwanais ont donc effectué
je vous le disais des manœuvres de tirs
réel sur l'île de Pingtung au sud une
île qui se trouve donc entre la Chine
continentale et Taïwan c'était hier soir
écoute tout de suite le commandant
taïwanais de la division blindée
même si le gouvernement communiste
chinois récemment fait de nombreux
gestes injustifiés à notre égard dans le
but de provoquer des conflits entre les
deux parties nous ne serons pas
découragés nous nous préparons à la
guerre mais nous ne la cherchons pas
nous nous battrons mais ne cherchons pas
les conflits nous poursuivrons
l'entraînement pour élever les
compétences de combat de chaque soldat
nous demandons à nos compatriotes de
croire et d'avoir foi en nous
Antoine escalade aujourd'hui des
tensions est-ce qu'il y a un changement
de ton du côté de Taipei il y a très
certainement ce qu'on pourrait qualifier
de quatrième crise dans le détroit
Taïwan après les deux crises des années
50 et la crise de la fin des années 90
mais c'est une crise qui a été initiée
par la Chine en utilisant le prétexte de
la visite de Nancy Pelosi sur l'île mais
pour l'instant du côté de Taïwan la
réponse elle est extrêmement mesurée
elle est fermée
on l'a vu au mois d'août l'objectif du
gouvernement mais aussi des armées
taïonnaises étaient de ne pas rentrer
dans le jeu de la Chine de montrer
qu'ils étaient prêts à défendre le pays
mais qu'il n'allait pas chercher la
provocation qui n'allait pas chercher le
contact avec les forces chinoises et
aujourd'hui hier soir également d'après
ce que on est sur le territoire de
Taïwan sont des exercices militaires
relativement classiques l'objectif faut
bien comprendre c'est d'envoyer un
message à la Chine mais aussi d'envoyer
un message à la population taïwanaise 2
et on le voyait bien dans le dans
l'extrait de convaincre la population
taïwanaise que l'absence de réaction
trop forte de l'armée taïwennaise elle
est voulue elle est réfléchie l'objectif
c'est d'éviter une escalade tout en
démontrant la détermination et c'est
très important les capacités de l'armée
taïwanaise puisque parfois certains
peuvent en douter Jean-François des
milliers donc pas d'escalade c'est ce
que dit Antoine mondaz doit être
d'accord juste tension effectivement on
montre les muscles la question on n'est
pas dans la situation où on était il y a
trois mois pour des raisons qui viennent
d'être rappelés la vraie question qu'il
faut se poser c'est est-ce que la
pression que la Chine a commencé à
mettre au moment de la visite de Nancy
et comme le dit Antoine au prétexte de
la visite de Nancy mélodie parce que ce
qu'on a vu juste après la visite de
Nancy pélosie ne pouvait pas avoir été
improvisé au moment où on a su que la
sédatrice allait venir donc c'était prêt
et la question c'est ce qu'on a un effet
de cliquer à savoir que désormais la
barre est placée à ce niveau là donc
d'une certaine façon plus haut et le mot
d'escalade doit être repris que ce qu'on
avait auparavant ou bien effectivement
est-ce qu'on va avoir des vagues
d'acalmie de moments plus apaisés
c'est certainement pas la volonté de la
Chine et ça dépend aussi de la situation
intérieure chinoise il n'y a pas que la
situation taïw
ce que on peut pas dire ils sont prêts
justement ils sont ils prennent à
accepter le bien donc cette attitude là
depuis là depuis le problème donc 2019
je pense que le temps à faire son chemin
et que le tawanais si près pas ici
prépare André vaigny vous êtes membre je
le rappelle la commission des affaires
étrangères il y a des sénateurs français
qui sont arrivés à Taïwan comme Olivier
Cadic et vice-président de la commission
des affaires étrangères il a dit Taïwan
n'est pas seul on va l'écouter je vous
ferai agir
non après la démonstration est faite
j'avais aussi rappelé un proverbe
chinois une baguette seul et il a cassé
une 10 baguettes en forme sondio comme
faire et donc c'est effectivement c'est
le fait qu'on a vu depuis un an les pays
les se lever les uns après les autres
pour marquer
one et donc c'est un
véritablement quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui
progresse on a vu la déclaration du G7
récemment justement après la visite de
Nancy pédosi puisque les décisions
chinoises de leurs exercices militaires
étaient vraiment injustifiée c'était une
véritable escalade et donc je pense que
aujourd'hui la démonstration est faite
que Taïwan n'est pas seul Taïwan n'est
pas seul pardon pour les problèmes de
santé valide est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord donc avec ce que vient de dire
Olivier caddy qu'est-ce que c'est
important d'être là-bas pour dire à ta
vous n'êtes pas seul face à la Chine oui
c'est très important je pense qu'il faut
saisir toutes les occasions qui se
présentent de montrer notre solidarité à
l'égard du peuple taïwanais qui est un
peuple courageux un peuple qui fait face
à une menace considérable la menace
chinoise et la diplomatie française les
diplomaties européennes la diplomatie
européenne si elle existe doivent saisir
toutes les occasions y compris la
diplomatie parlementaire si tenter
qu'elle existe toutes les occasions de
montrer au taïwanais qu'ils ne sont pas
seuls et que nous ne resterons pas sans
réagir au cas où la Chine envahirait
Taïwan
il est possible que j'y aille avant la
fin de l'année dans le cas d'un autre
groupe parlementaire avec notamment le
sénateur André gatelin mais je crois
qu'il faut y aller il faut y aller
chaque fois que l'on peut et moi je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec ceux qui
disent que Nancy Pelosi a eu raison d'y
aller il ne faut pas céder aux
intimidations chinoises certains qui
disent que c'est une provocation qu'il
fallait pas justement qu'elle y aille
non c'est pas une provocation un
antipologie avait prévu d'y aller à la
fait on va revenir justement sur Taïwan
sur le statut de cette île 23 millions
d'habitants c'est une île qui n'a pas
toujours été chinoise on va revenir un
petit peu sur son histoire parce que
c'est important pour ce débat il y a eu
200 ans de domination chinoise des
mandchoue la dyslexie daking vous allez
bien sûr en parler Antoine bandas
probablement mieux que moi mais elle a
été aussi une colonie portugaise elle a
été une colonie hollandaise et elle a
été livrée par les Chinois aux Japonais
en 1895 donc après la défaite de la
Chine contre le Japon c'était l'air
Medji donc il y a eu 50 ans de
domination chinoise en revanche elle a
été ensuite redonnée à la Chine du temps
de chankaite après la défaite des
Japonais après la deuxième guerre
mondiale ce qui veut bien dire Antoine
Bondaz qu'en fait le droit international
et du côté des Chinois dans cette
histoire c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
puisqu'il y a eu deux grandes
conventions et de grandes réunions
conférence internationale la conférence
de Postdam la conférence du Caire qui
mentionne la question de Taïwan mais à
l'époque qui ne se prononce pas
forcément sur l'appropriation entre cas
de Taïwan par rapport à un régime
politique donc il y a évidemment sur le
plan juridique des quelque chose qui qui
est un peu compliqué mais ce qui est
important en plus il n'est pas aux
Nations Unies justement n'est pas aux
Nations Unies
il y a toujours eu un siège de la Chine
depuis 45 aux Nations Unies c'est pour
ça qu'on parle d'une seule Chine par
contre le siège a été occupé de 45 à 71
par la République de Chine Taipei puis
depuis 71 par la République populaire de
Chine Pékin mais au-delà de cette seule
Chine les différents pays notamment les
États-Unis le Japon ne se prononce pas
sur la question de savoir si Taïwan fait
ou non partie de la République populaire
de Chine et c'est là toute la nuance
d'hier Chine dit République populaire ce
n'est pas la même chose et aujourd'hui
ce qu'on appelle la politique d'une
seule Chine aux États-Unis au Japon et
dans l'immense majorité des pays
européens c'est de considérer qu'il n'y
a qu'une seule chaîne nous avons tous
des relations diplom avec la République
populaire de Chine il y en a que 14 qui
ont des relations avec la République de
Chine mais on ne dit pas que Taïwan fait
partie de la République populaire de
Chine on ne dit pas que Pékin à la
souveraineté sur l'île de Taïwan donc
une sorte de sous-entendu ah oui c'est
une sorte d'ambiguïté mais il faut
maintenir cette ambiguïté parce que si
on sort de cette ambiguïté les risques
sont considérables
risquent de la part de la Chine si on
reconnaît Taïwan comme un État
indépendant risque de d'irriter et plus
que ça encore la Chine populaire et
pourtant c'est ce qu'il souhaite enfin
magnifiques à ce moment l'ambassadeur de
Taïwan en France qu'on a eu sur ce
plateau la semaine dernière eux
aimeraient qu'on reconnaisse
l'indépendance
je crois que pour le moment l'ambiguïté
est plutôt salutaire y compris pour
Taïwan
la grande la grande habilité de la
présidente élue au suffrage
une personnalité élue pour sa modération
au sein de son parti qui est un parti
souvent qualifiée d'indépendantistes et
de ne jamais traverser la ligne rouge et
précisément cette ambiguïté je ne suis
pas sûr que même François whou le
représentant de Taipei à Paris est en
vie d'en sortir de cette ambiguïté
d'ailleurs
si ils vont sortir je voudrais revenir
sur la question du droit vous allez
soulever parce que effectivement
Antoine Bondaz rappelait que du point de
vue du droit on pouvait être une
certaine façon interpréter que le droit
était en faveur de la Chine mais ce qui
est extrêmement ironique dans cette
histoire c'est si on regarde les autres
conflits territoriaux où les autres
tensions territoriales qu'il y a dans la
région la mère de Chine du Sud par
exemple qu'a dit la Chine en face du
droit international qu'a dit la Chine en
face du tribunal d'arbitrage de la Haye
lorsqu'on lui a dit qu'effectivement et
bien
ne faisait rien à la faire mais qu'il y
avait un droit international elle ne l'a
pas reconnu parce qu'elle a voulu que ce
soit l'histoire qui prévalle en disant
mais non cette merde de sinus sud elle
est à nous historiquement et donc
l'histoire en l'occurrence c'est
contraire au droit mais dans cette
situation c'est le signe qui se
préoccupe du droit alors que dans la
situation de sud elle ne se prévoit pas
du droit
internationalaise comme on dit
une partie de l'histoire qu'on a très
peu mentionné ce qui renversait
l’éternité
c'est pas c'est pas le communiste c'est
République Chine donc c'est Taïwan c'est
comington qu'ils ont renversé la
dernière dynastie 1911 la création de la
Chine proprement dit moderne c'est par
le comington et jusqu'au 49 donc c'est
parti l'histoire ici oui
donc c'était République de Chine donc
c'est le Taïwan qui sont récupérés
aujourd'hui cette non c'est entité donc
si c'est parti de là 1911 je suis sur 49
si on reconnait pas le République Chine
l'existence du coup il y a une partie de
l'histoire de Chine qui s'évaporait qui
était écrit par les par les vainqueurs
donc la république populaire de la Chine
est-ce qu'il y a une nation taïwanaise
pour vous sénateurs une nation ça dépend
ce qu'on met dans le mot nation sur le
plan juridique sur le plan politique sur
le plan à se bat contre la Chine un peu
comme les Ukrainiens se battent comme on
contre les Russes
est pertinent parce que lorsque Poutine
a décidé d'agresser l'Ukraine tout le
monde pensait ou presque tout le monde
pensait que il n'en aurait que pour
quelques semaines avant d'avaler une
partie de l'Ukraine voir l'Ukraine tout
entière y compris Kiev et on s'aperçoit
six mois après que ça n'est pas si
facile que ça y compris pour la grande
armée russe et je pense que les Chinois
réfléchissent maintenant à deux fois
avant d'envisager ce qu'ils ont quand
même derrière la tête avant d'envisager
d'envahir Taïwan Taïwan est bien équipée
Taïwan est soutenu militairement par les
États-Unis et demain on dit que en 2025
l'armée chinoise sera prête ce que
disent les Taiwanais en 2025 elle sera
prête je crois qu'ils vont réfléchir par
exemple ukrainien mais il est en faveur
Taïwan vous pensez la même chose en tant
que bondage parce qu'effectivement on
peut pas ne pas parler de la guerre en
Ukraine est-ce que c'est un est-ce que
les Taïwanais donc utilisent voix Hong
Kong et la guerre en Ukraine un peu
comme des exemples sur la manière dont
d'ailleurs la communauté internationale
va ou pas traiter le problème de Taïwan
sont deux catalyseurs pour la société
taïwanaise qui comprennent que un pays
de système c'est une utopie c'est un
fantasme qui ne peut pas fonctionner et
que deuxièmement il faut avoir les
moyens de se défendre y compris des
moyens au niveau de la société et pour
revenir très rapidement sur la question
de la nation taïwanaise et de l'identité
taïwanaise parce que souvent les
diplomates chinois explique que les
Taïwanais étaient favorables à la
réification avant puis se considérait
comme chinois mais évidemment que dans
les années 50 et 60 les taïwanaises
considérés comme chinois puisque vous
aviez un régime dictatorial qui imposait
à l'école dans toute la vie avec les
héritiers exactement de la grande Chine
qui
indiqué à l'époque il faut le
reconnaître revendiquer le territoire du
continent mais tout cela a changé avec
la démocratisation alors ça c'est
important
démocratisation a permis l'émergence
d'une identité taïwanaise et la
démocratisation c'est aussi fait du côté
de Taïwan avec la constitution du
véritable nation puisqu'aujourd'hui les
Taïwanais ne revendiquent pas le
continent alors que les Chinois
revendiquent-ils et c'est ça toute la
différence les Taïwanais de demande que
une chose qu'on les laisse tranquille
entre guillemets qui puisse continuer
avec leur système politique leur système
social or la Chine aujourd'hui
communiste veut prendre le contrôle de
Taïwan donc on se retrouve en fait dans
un combat entre une démocratie et un
régime autocratique où est-ce que ça va
quand même plus loin
c'est pas seulement le régime politique
je pense qu'au contraire on ne peut pas
aller plus loin que ce débat parce que
pourquoi est-ce que à 10000 km de
distance avec la relative le faible
l'information malgré les efforts que
nous ont tous des populations
européennes sur ce qui se passe là-bas
pourquoi est-ce que ça nous concerne ça
nous concerne pas simplement parce que
comme on vient de le dire jusqu'ici il y
a un conflit territorial il y a des lois
il y a un historique mais parce que il y
a un système démocratique qui est notre
et qui est en partie plus avant c'est
que le nôtre on a une démocratie
participative des années 2000 grosso
modo
la jeunesse c'est que vous pouvez
inventer des choses qui ne sont pas
inventées
participative avec un système qui a eu
des heures et des malheurs depuis 10 ou
15 ans c'est à dire des systèmes de
référendum auxquels vous avez accès très
facilement qui est en train d'être
corrigé aujourd'hui mais qui est un
exemple de démocratie pas simplement
parce qu'ils sont en face de la Chine
mais parce qu'ils sont dans une région
qui a une vraie aspiration démocratique
en Corée
au Japon on a aussi une certaine forme
de démocratie et c'est cela qui nous
intéresse
que ça nous intéresse et c'est pour cela
qu'il est important effectivement que
des personnalités comme le sénateur qui
représentent le système législatif qui
nous est propre avec trois pouvoirs bien
distincts ce que parfois on ne comprend
pas en Chine continentale et bien tout
ça est représenté la Taïwan comme chez
nous
est un hérican un irritant pour pour
Pékin la société taïwanais c'est une
société de fait de culture chinoise même
s'il y a des influences également
étrangères japonaises européennes et
autres qui a connu un régime autoritaire
extrêmement violent la Terreur blanche à
Taïwan dans les années 40 50 60 a fait
des dizaines de milliers de morts
mais qui s'est démocratisé de
l'intérieur et ça pour le Parti
communiste chinois c'est un
contre-exemple extrêmement gênant c'est
à dire que l'argument à Pékin de dire
aujourd'hui la culture chinoise des
valeurs traditionnelles font qu'il faut
un régime fort que il faut assumer entre
guillemets sans le dire cette forme
d'autoritarisme Taïwan montre qui a un
universalisme de la démocratie et qu'on
peut évidemment être de culture chinoise
et être démocratie vous le permettez je
vais reprendre ma comparaison avec la
Russie et l'Ukraine c'est pas une
obsession mais ce que vient dire antoine
bondase va dans le sens de ce que je
disais à l'instant à savoir que ce qui a
motivé Poutine d'après ce qu'on peut
savoir c'est pas tellement le fantasme
de reconstituer l'empire des tsar ou
même la grande union soviétique c'est
qu'il ne supportait pas que l'Ukraine
aux portes de la Russie se démocratise
qu'elles deviennent une sorte de modèle
démocratique nouveau en Europe centrale
et orientale c'est ça que tu n'as pas
supporter Poutine parce que l'Ukraine a
réussi son très proches il y a chaque
russe a de la famille en Ukraine et
inversement c'est la même chose à Taïwan
et en Chine les Chinois les communistes
chinois ne supportent pas la démocratie
taiwanaise car ils ont peur d'une
contamination entre guillemets en tout
cas si je reprends les dires de la
présidente de Taïwan donc Madame elle a
écrit donc il y a pas longtemps dans la
revue forêt friends si Taïwan tombait
les conséquences seraient
catastrophiques pour la paix régionale
et le système d'alliance démocratique ce
serait le signe que dans la compétition
mondiale des valeurs l'autocratie
l'emporterait sur la démocratie donc là
elle essaye véritablement de mobiliser
les démocraties dont les États-Unis bien
sûr mais il y a aussi l'identité
taïwanais existe claire et bien et
solidement surtout il parlait la langue
et il écrit non simplifié donc une
langue qu'il était perdue dans la en
Chine continentale exactement comme Hong
Kong donc c'est l'endroit qui préserve
le maximum de culture traditionnelle
chinoise et quand tous les cran écrivain
chinois de Chine continental pour la
première fois visiter à Taïwan l'année
2000 il s'est étonné que la civilisation
civilisation préserver la politesse les
façons
donc c'est la faute à qui si jimping
Antoine mondes pour faire simple
reprendre les Taïwanais ne sont pas anti
chinois les Taïwanais veulent juste
préserver leur modèle tout simplement on
n'a pas des taïwanais qui vont en Chine
en disant changer votre modèle qui vont
en Chine en disant on a des
revendications territoriales on a des
taïwanais qui disent nous sommes une
démocratie nous voulons la garder et ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est que
depuis 2016 la Chine exerce une pression
sur Taïwan depuis l'élection de la
prison Taïwan qui est sans précédent sur
le plan politique économique la colère
le changement
ça fera partie de la Chine et quoi qu'il
arrive le changement aujourd'hui il
vient de Chine c'est la Chine qui veut
changer le statu quo on le voit quand la
Chine veut empêcher des parlementaires
étrangers se rendre à Taïwan et c'est
vraiment ça l'enjeu parce que pour Pékin
l'objectif il est clair c'est prendre le
contrôle de Taïwan ce n'est pas réunifié
puisque Taïwan n'a jamais fait partie de
la République populaire c'est prendre le
contrôle c'est l'objectif de Shining il
ne peut pas le faire aujourd'hui par la
séduction c'était un des objectifs dans
les années 2000 ça ne marche plus donc
il faut le faire par la coercition
Jean-François
aujourd'hui en fait vraiment une idée
d'ailleurs d'après ce que j'ai entendu
dire il faudrait faire il faut réunifier
avant 2049 parce que ça sera le centième
et universel de la Révolution commune
chinoise il y a de très bons ouvrages
qui vous décrivent ce qu'il y a dans la
tête de Sitting l'un de vos confrères a
écrit quelque chose de remarquable
François bouh on ne sait pas ce qu'il y
a dans la dans la tête de Sitting en
revanche on peut imaginer qu'il y a des
priorités d'ordre différents il est
évident que tout ce qui a été dit
jusqu'ici sur la situation intérieure en
quelque sorte de la Chine et sur les
objectifs du Parti communiste et
fondamental néanmoins il y a une
dimension qu'on va certainement évoquer
au fil de la conversation qui est aussi
la dimension géostratégique la Chine en
fait quand on regarde une carte la Chine
on l'appelle Chine continental
précisément et c'est pas un hasard c'est
qu'en fait d'une certaine façon quand
vous regardez une carte et bien elle est
enfermée dans une masse continentale
aujourd'hui dans des conflits potentiels
ou en tout cas dans le jeu
géostratégique il est important de
pouvoir sortir comme on dit dans les
eaux bleues et pas simplement dans les
eaux brunes or le collier d'îles qui
commence à la Corée qui continue avec
Taïwan et qui continue un peu plus loin
dans cette fameuse mère de Chine du Sud
qui fait tant de peine à la Chine
continentale enferme la flotte chinoise
malgré sa capacité effectivement à
sortir et donc fait la démonstration
mais j'ai aussi des raisons stratégiques
indépendamment de l'idéologie
géostratégiquement c'est important et
puis bien sûr on va aussi parler du
sujet technologique puisque Taïwan c'est
une extraordinaire expérience de
développement technologique et à ce jour
on n'a pas la preuve que malgré les
sommes très importantes et le retard
accumulée en Chine on puisse avoir en
Chine un compétiteur efficace de tout ce
qui est fait à Taïwan aujourd'hui donc
il y a aussi cet objectif probablement
même si c'est probablement aussi un
objectif qui est ambigu parce que se
saisir de Taïwan pas ne veut pas
forcément dire mettre un terme à la
production de ces fameuses puces de TSMC
ailleurs qu'à Taïwan est d'ailleurs ça
fait peut-être partie des faiblesses du
dispositif de défense taïwanais en tout
cas ça fait partie des enjeux André
vanille d'ailleurs il y a des
coopérations d'après ce que disait le
sénateur qui se trouve en ce moment sur
place justement dans le domaine des
semi-conducteurs avec la France avec
l'Europe
assure son territoire le leader mondial
des semi-conducteurs TSMC qui est un
modèle de réussite économique au niveau
mondial mais je reviens d'un mot sur ce
qui vient d'être dit que je partage bien
sûr Taïwan est un enjeu géostratégique
pour la Chine un enjeu économique c'est
aussi un enjeu politique on va voir ce
que va dire que si j'ai une ping au
Congrès du Parti communiste qui s'ouvre
très prochainement parce que la Chine va
moins bien économiquement la Chine a des
problèmes internes la classe moyenne
patine si j'ose dire au plan du niveau
de vie et je pense que comme c'est
toujours le cas le dictateur KSI Jinping
je dis le dictateur que si Jean Ping va
sans doute servir à nouveau de Taïwan
pour flatter le nationalisme chinois
n'oubliez pas qu'en 2020 je crois le
Premier ministre chinois a omis dans son
discours de palais de réunification
Pacifique il a dit réunification tout
court on va voir ce que va dire que si
j'ai une pink c'est très intéressant
parce que je le répète l'économie c'est
important la stratégie l'environnement
la mer du Sud la mère de Chine du Sud
bien sûr mais la politique intérieure
compte aussi beaucoup pour que jimping
les États-Unis pour parler de tout de
même évidemment ces stratégique cette
zone pour eux aussi ils ont vendu pour
1,1 milliard de dollars d'armes à la
République de Chine donc à Taïwan ça
c'était la semaine dernière pourquoi à
votre avis tamaha a lui un tel
engagement des Américains on sent qu'il
y a des dissensions tout de même entre
Joe Biden qui reste prudent et par
exemple quelqu'un comme Nancy Pelosi ou
d'autres parlementaires américains qui
effectivement vont sur place qui veulent
faire plus pour Taïwan forcément les
deux qui jouaient pas le même rôle pelle
aussi il a pas plus cette ambition
d'être le président de comme d'autres
fois donc elle est fait c'est ce qu'ils
veulent c'est une femme de force et de
conviction et en même temps Taiwan
USA c'est toujours leur refuge de Taïwan
taïwanais l'ensemble qui sort le
politique même au sein de population la
première vraiment le premier plus grand
immigration de vagues il migratoire des
Chinois vers le
verset jeunes c'est taïwanais c'est
tawanais ils ont créé le premier
génération ils ont fait les études de
aujourd'hui on a vu beaucoup de visage
asiatique au sein de clairement
américain saisons est d'origine
taïwanaise donc cette force constituée
en Amérique ça crée une retour au sein
de pays taïwanais c'était l'Amérique
c'est toujours la règle en tout cas le
rêve un peu plus dans le technologie
dans la connaissance pour les Taïwan et
donc la protection de télés américains
tu Mania qui soit historique autant le
géostratégique des Américains ça fait ça
fait partie de l'enjeu pour les
Américains alors justement toi de mondaz
est-ce que effectivement les Américains
s'engageraient jusqu'au bout s'il y
avait un conflit militaire lancer par
Pékin à Taïwan est-ce qu'ils iraient
parce qu'il y a un acte j'ai eu le
Taïwan reulation hack de 1979 qui
n'engage les États-Unis qu'à fournir à
l'île des moyens de se défendre pour
l'instant on en est là alors le talent
va en réalité un petit peu plus loin il
mentionne notamment quand
d'embargo ou de blocus cela
constituerait une menace pour les
intérêts américains dans la région et
pour la stabilité régionale ce qui
sous-entend que les Américains
pourraient intervenir et c'est là
l'ambiguïté stratégique des Américains
aujourd'hui si la Chine envahit Taïwan
je pense que personne ne doute à Taïwan
aux États-Unis que les Américains
interviendraient mais ils enverrai des
questions alors la question c'est ça la
question c'est sous quelle forme la
livraison d'armes comme en Ukraine par
exemple l'envoi de troupe
est-ce qu'on détruit des équipements
chinois dans le détroit est-ce qu'on va
jusqu'à détruire sur le continent ça
c'est la vraie question et les
Américains sur ce point n'ont jamais été
explicites et ils ont toujours voulu
garder l'ambiguïté si vous permettez
Monsieur Bondaz Joe Biden a une phrase
au mois de juillet je crois pour dire
évidemment nous interviendrons bien sûr
et ensuite il a rétropédalé si j'ose
dire il a senti qu'il était allé un peu
trop loin donc il y a une ambiguïté qui
est maintenue parce que l'objectif c'est
de la maintenir George en 2001 dit nous
défendrons à evoine et c'est une
expression qui est restée extrêmement
connue where Tex quoi qu'il en coûte le
français cette expression et donc là
dessus il y a pas d'ambiguïté sur le
fait qu'ils interviendraient la question
c'est sous quelle forme mais surtout la
priorité des priorités américaines c'est
d'éviter d'avoir à intervenir c'est de
livrer notamment des armes on parle d'un
milliard aurait été c'est pas beaucoup
en 2010 la seule année 2010 plus de 10
milliards 2016 plus de 10 milliards donc
c'est des montants qui sont assez
faibles pour l'instant la vraie question
tu montes en puissance mais la question
pour les Taiwanais c'est quels sont les
types d'équipements qu'il faut
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il faut des choses
très visibles pour rassurer la
population taïwanaise et c'est important
où est-ce qu'il faut des capacités avant
tout asymétriques de plus petites
dimensions très mobiles qui dans le
cadre d'une guerre face à un géant
militaire chinois en terme de de masse
serait très utile et encore une fois cet
objectif américain d'éviter un conflit
si l'objectif de la France c'est
l'objectif des Européens de dire et
c'est l'élément de langage que
Anne-Claire Legendre utilisé sur votre
chaîne hier l'objectif de la France
c'est de maintenir le statu quo et de
s'opposer à tout changement unilatéral
et par la force de ce statu quo et
Jean-François d'immigli alors justement
cette île elle est très montagneuse
est-ce qu'elle serait extrêmement
difficile si on parle juste d'un point
de vue militaire pour les Chinois de
l'envahir parce que la question que vous
avez en 1949 lorsque tchangacheck est
parti avec yvet quoi un million un
million et demi et de chinois qui sont
partis avec lui en 1949 au moment où Mao
donc remporte la bataille et bien à ce
moment-là Mao a renoncé ou pas enfin il
n'est pas allé il a pas conquis cette
île oui alors que vous comment le
rappeler il y a eu ensuite les crises
des années 50 c'est à dire que on avait
une espèce de jeu de rôle pendant
lesquels on avait cette alternance de
bombardements il est un jour père ou une
partie bombardait l'autre mais
effectivement il y a eu comme d'ailleurs
au moment de la Révolution culturelle en
face de Hong Kong la révolution
culturelle s'est arrêtée aux portes de
Hong Kong il y a eu quand même à une
certaine époque je ne dirais pas une
prudence mais en tout cas un calcul
relativement rationnel de du coup
avantage de la part des communistes
pendant très longtemps et Mao qui est un
stratège à très longtemps effectivement
penché de ce côté là ça peut expliquer
effectivement ce qui s'est ce qui s'est
ce qui s'est ce qui s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé jusque là
c'était la situation jusque là je
voudrais revenir sur le Taïwan où il est
chez Direct et
ce qu'il contient ce qu'il peut ce qu'il
peut ce qu'il peut entraîner parce que
effectivement l'Europe a fait une très
bonne déclaration tout qu'à la France à
travers la porte-parole du ministère des
Affaires étrangères mais nous n'avons
pas l'équivalent c'est très difficile
bien sûr de concevoir un équivalent dans
la mesure où une relation historique
avec Taïwan ne sont pas celles de des
Etats-Unis
je pense qu'il y a un travail à faire du
point de vue législatif et diplomatique
aussi pour trouver la phrase et logique
correcte qu'il ne soit pas une phrase
jolie provocatrice mais qui néanmoins
affirme de façon irréfutable que ce que
nous disons lors de tel ou tel événement
puisse être suivi des faits c'est-à-dire
oui
nous nous y employons chaque fois qu'on
le peut au niveau du Parlement français
au Sénat en tout cas nous avons voté en
2021 je crois une résolution j'étais
intervenu à la tribune sur ce sujet une
résolution qui exigeait que la Chine
accepte que Taïwan puisse siéger à l'OMS
alors l'Organisation de l'aviation
civile internationale aux organisations
internationales sur le climat car il
faut savoir que la Chine empêche
interdit à Taïwan de siéger dans ses
organisations internationales au
prétexte que ce n'est pas un état
souverain or s'il y a un pays qui a
particulièrement bien réussi en matière
de lutte contre le covid c'est Taïwan
donc on a pris une résolution pour
demander que Taïwan puisse siéger à
l'OMS pour le moment ça n'est pas le cas
nous devons multiplier toutes les
initiatives possibles vous avez raison
monsieur di maiglio pour que pour dire à
Taïwan nous sommes avec vous et pour
faire réfléchir si gimping parce que
vous avez raison Mao a fait un calcul
coavantage d'une intervention d'une
invasion de Taïwan fait la même chose
que Mao à mon avis et si tu veux la paix
prépare la guerre nous devons aider
Taïwan à préparer une invasion pour
dissuader les Chinois d'envahir Taïwan
par exemple européen justement dans un
qui puisse réguler entre guillemets les
relations entre les Européens sont pas
très friands
précisément si vous voulez au moment
justement où sitting va rencontrer
Poutine j'entendais sur une une chaîne
où j'intervenais qui qui qui n'est pas
là vous cet après-midi une espèce de
fatalisme de l'avancée inexorable des
régimes forts finalement
les interlocuteurs disaient imposent
leur loi mais nous avons des lois nous
avons aussi la capacité de les rédiger
de façon subtile sans être provoquant et
de trouver la bonne voie s'exprimer un
point je vois les Américains n'ont pas
envie sans doute aucune envie de te
ménopause sur le territoire en Asie mais
en même temps il essayait de inciter les
autres pays asiatiques se protéger
serait armés comme au Japon donc il y a
un très bon exemple et qu'ils ont les
bases américains il est déjà installé
encore eu du Sud dans tous ces partis là
l'intopacifique c'est Sarah un point de
bascule pour tous ces enjeux
géopolitique dont les Américains je
pense qu'ils ont déjà bien préparé le
terrain de l'Europe oui mais les
Américains aussi c'est important il y a
une course aux armement pratiquement
aujourd'hui dans cette zone aujourd'hui
collaborer et puis bien longtemps que
les Européens n'ont pas encore eu de psy
l'Europe est en retard sur les
États-Unis sur la lucidité à l'égard de
la Chine populaire à l'égard de la Chine
communiste avec tous ces défauts Trump a
eu au moins se mérite et Dieu Cessy
comme beaucoup j'exécre Trump et sa
façon de faire de la politique il a eu
un avantage c'est qu'il a ouvert les
yeux des Américains et des Européens sur
la menace chinoise la menace commerciale
alors les Américains ont de l'avance sur
nous ça remonte à Obama ce qu'on a
appelé le pivot vers l'Indopacifique
c'est Obama le premier qui a dit aux
Européens débrouillez-vous vous-même
maintenant on va s'occuper de
l'Indo-Pacifique c'est Obama qui a
commencé Trump a continué ça continue
avec Biden il faut que les Européens
fassent davantage preuve de lucidité ça
a commencé
un certain nombre de sanctions
économiques on sait que les rats
franchement c'est quoi la Chine et le
premier partenaire commercial de
l'Europe la question c'est pas de
prendre des sanctions c'est pas de
rentrer dans un jeu où on prendrait des
sanctions la Chine prenait des contre
sanctions c'est de changer un peu le
logiciel et le débat premièrement qu'il
y ait un débat en France sur notre
relation avec la Chine
c'est un grand absent des enjeux au sein
des partis politiques il y a pas de
débat sur la relation qu'on a avec la
Chine alors même que la Chine
politique envers la Chine aussi
aujourd'hui la Chine faut que les
Français comprennent la machine c'est 30
% des émissions 30 % des émissions de
SSR vous ne pouvez pas avoir une
diplomatie climatique qui n'inclut pas
la Chine la Chine donc c'est à dire il
faut discuter avec la Chine ce qui est
produit en Chine a un impact sur les
emplois en France sur l'inflation ou pas
en France c'est-à-dire que le facteur
chinois il est il est fondamental et
aujourd'hui pendant des années on a
considéré qu'on pouvait convaincre la
Chine par exemple d'aller vers davantage
de réciprocité ça n'a pas marché naïveté
et ce n'est pas marché pendant 20 ans
aujourd'hui que ça a marché et donc
aujourd'hui au niveau européen notamment
l'objectif c'est de faire de la
réciprocité vers le bas si la Chine
n'ouvre pas ses marchés on va
contraindre l'accès à nos marchés du
point de vue
de l'arrivée des Chinois ça peut être
sur la question du contrôle
d'investissement sur le mécanisme
anti-coercession sur l'accès au marché
public etc c'est des sujets qui sont
discutés en ce moment même au niveau de
la commission certains ont déjà été
adoptés mais l'objectif c'est d'avoir
une discussion lucide sur évidemment
qu'il est important d'avoir des
relations avec la Chine mais il faut
être lucide sur ce que nous pouvons
obtenir et sur la façon surtout de
l'obtenir cet accord oui tout à fait
d'accord bien il faut changer on a été
naïf trop longtemps à l'égard de la
Chine on devient lucide il n'est jamais
trop tard pour bien faire mais les
Européens les Français mais pas
seulement vous savez le problème de
l'Europe c'est que on est 27 et que on
n'est pas toujours d'accord sur tout et
notamment en Europe centrale et
orientale certains pays sont soumis à
une influence chinoise grandissante et
ça c'est un vrai souci pour l'Europe
occidentale puis les Allemands ont quand
même un certain nombre d'accord
économiques avec avec la Chine donc
là-dessus ils se distingue aussi et puis
au niveau français il faut être clair il
y a le niveau très politique il y a le
niveau des administrations vous pouvez
écouter le secrétaire général à la
défense et la sécurité nationale qui
était en audition de mémoire au mois de
juillet à l'Assemblée nationale qui
parlait de l'espionnage chinois attire
l'arrigot c'est le pression qu'il a
utilisé le fait et c'est sorti dans la
presse que la DGSI en matière de
contre-ingérence économique par exemple
et beaucoup plus actif qu'auparavant
donc les choses sont en train d'évoluer
mais disons qu'on a pas forcément encore
le débat vraiment politique sur la
relation avec la Chine elle est
compliquée nous n'avons pas obtenu de
concession il va falloir changer parce
que la relation de fait même si on ne le
souhaite pas dire de plus en plus
confrontationnelle même si ce n'est
évidemment pas l'intérêt de personne
qu'il y a une guerre et c'est évidemment
pas le prochain français justement il
nous reste cinq minutes est-ce que la
guerre est inévitable tout de même
est-ce que le Pékin finira par envahir
Taïwan il faut relire Giraudoux qui lui
était persuadé qu'à partir d'un certain
moment la guerre était inévitable mais
heureusement il s'est passé à peu près
80 ans depuis giraudou je pense qu'un
certain nombre de crise que ce soit des
crises financières que soit des crises
climatiques ont ou sanitaires ont
démontré qu'on avait appris des choses
quand même depuis 60 ou 70 ans donc il
faut faire confiance effectivement
à la connexion d'un certain nombre de
bonnes volontés y compris en Chine la
Chine a une très longue histoire
derrière elle mais elle a aussi une très
longue histoire devant elle et quand on
maintient le dialogue avec la Chine
c'est aussi parce qu'on pense à la Chine
du futur et c'est à celle-là aussi qu'on
s'adresse déjà en particulier
que tout ça c'est c'est une
communication c'est une conversion
envers la population chinoise aussi qui
sont complètement en perm les Chinois
les jeunes aujourd'hui ils ont quatre
aspirations c'était n'est pas se marier
n'est pas fait des enfants n'est pas
acheté de maison et ne rien faire donc
vis-à-vis d'une situation une population
une jeunesse qu'ils en perle
complètement à ce point là la seule
chose c'est de poster leur envie c'est
la nationalisme donc je pense que ça
c'est c'est on verra peut-être avec ton
temporaire un peu et puis on verra je
sens toutes les situations évoluer en
revaniable sur le nationalisme que veut
flatter que si j'ai une ping euh on
vient de citer Giraudoux moi je
remontais beaucoup plus loin encore je
vais citer tussidy de fameux piège de
tussidie quand une puissance impériale
voit un rivale montée en puissance donc
les États-Unis voyant la Chine monter en
puissance il était inévitable disait tu
signé à l'époque de la Grèce antique il
est inévitable qu'un conflit éclate
entre ces deux géants et je pense que
Taïwan pourrait hélas pour être hélas
l'objet de ce conflit Antoine réponse de
de politesse la guerre elle est toujours
évitable parce que c'est une décision
politique et donc c'est aux dirigeants
d'éviter qu'il y a un conflit et
aujourd'hui le rôle de la France et de
l'Union européenne en accord et en
coordination avec d'autres pays c'est de
convaincre la Chine que ce n'est pas
dans son intérêt d'essayer de changer de
façon unilatérale et par la force le
statu quoique
et puissante et les États-Unis sont
puissants d'autres pays sont puissants
et en tout cas on doit contribuer même
si notre rôle n'est pas un rôle
primordial on doit contribuer à essayer
de maintenir ce statu quo un souvenir en
tout cas que cette guerre elle est tout
à fait possible merci beaucoup avoir été
avec nous Antoine Bondaz Tamara lui
Merci à VOUS André Vallini merci
Jean-François diméglio merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivis et rester avec nous
sur France 24
[Musique]